I posted a vlog the other day
sharing a particularly busy day in the life
of the mother of three
and when I say particularly busy
that day was out the fkn gate
and if that day was a crazy day
then this day is gonna be the polar opposite
so because I don't really feel like leaving
the house or doing anything
unless I absolutely have to
so come spend a regular day in the life with me
my husband got up early and took the dog
for a run before heading off into work
and so I just had to deal with everything else
I gave the kids their breakfast
made their lunch packed their bags
got them ready for school and dropped
them off before coming home
and dealing with some admin
I caught up in my emails
took a zoom meeting
ordered my groceries
and edited some content before ripping into the household chores
which I was really hoping might do themselves
and the whole time I was making the beds
I was struggling with the urge just to hop back in
because I don't know what's going on with Goldie at the moment
but she seems to be having a sleep regression
Goldie is my two and a half year old vizsla
and lately she's been waking up five or six times a night
and sometimes she'll just come and stare at me
and I don't know why
anyway I'm extremely tired
and it reminds me
of that feeling that you get when you have a Newborn
which is why I am not gonna be having anymore Newborns
I opened a PR pack from Lorna Jane
before deciding to have a shower
and my shower turned into an everything shower
which even normally happens during the day
but I have a photoshoot tomorrow with BraveFace
so I justified it to myself by telling myself it was work
and my husband's not getting home till late
and by the time i get through the afternoon with the kids
I figured I'm not gonna wanna do any of this shit
so I might as well just do it
I raced out and pick the kids up from school
before dealing with the groceries
dealing with the kitchen
and then dealing with the bathroom
and this is one of my non negotiable daily clean areas
I mean obviously the kitchen gets cleaned multiple times a day
but the bathroom will get a surface clean
once a day and a deep clean once a week
and then please be assured
I thoroughly washed my hands before starting on the dinner
and then this is one of my lazy girl go to dinners
which I know the kids will eat every single time
and that I make when I really can't be fkd
making a proper dinner
and it's gonna look like a proper dinner and
taste like a proper dinner
but I swear to god
it takes like 10 minutes to make
I've got a variation of this saved under my Easy Recipes playlist
so basically
it's just onions
mushrooms chicken herbs
salt and pepper
lemon juice capers
a bit of mustard
chicken stock and cream
and I just pop it in the oven for like an hour and a half
stirring occasionally
and it basically cooks itself
and I must have been feeling particularly maternal today
because my kids just absolutely adore these cookies
so I decided to whip up a quick batch so that
they could have a hot cookie for pudding
let me know if you want the recipe for this by the way
because I could make these with my eyes closed
and again it's an easy recipe that takes extra no time
and you will find
if you follow me
that this is a consistent theme with a sort of food that I cook
it's gotta be quick
it's gotta be easy
and it's gonna be delicious
cause we don't have the time
capacity or patience to fk around and be fancy over here
I finished the dinner off with a bag of spinach
which disappeared into another dimension
added my cooked pasta
some Parmesan
and some fresh chopped basil
then I dished the kids up with a side of green beans
cause I figured
I'd eat later when my husband got home
and for their treat of course
they got a hot cookie
and no hot cookie is complete without a cup of milk
I got the babies clean
read them their stories
put them to sleep
then I sat down and did some prep for tomorrow
ate a cookie
and ignored my washing